you to have a nuanced conversation and
to tell the truth about what's going on
so I'm going to focus on two areas first
of all I'm Congressman Jamal Bowman I
represent New York 16th District which
covers the Northeast Bronx and part of
Southern Westchester County
so we're here for two aspects of this
conversation I want to start with the
aspect of free speech okay our first
amendment
gives us the right to speak freely and
to communicate freely
and Tick Tock as a platform has created
a community and a space for free speech
for a hundred and fifty million
Americans and Counting
that includes many of the content that's
right
that includes many of the content
creators that I just met with in my
office they talk about they talk to me
about a sense of family they talk to me
about a sense of community they talk to
me about a place that is helpful to
their mental health and to their sense
of belonging and well-being
they talked to me about finding a place
where they could communicate with others
like them and learn to love themselves
even further
and I so appreciate them being that
honest and vulnerable with me in terms
of how they engage with tick tock
Tick Tock is also not just a space of
for building Community but it's used as
an educational tool where you have
professors and teachers providing
content for students to engage with and
learn from
that is what Tick Tock is for so many
Americans
it's also a place where five million
small businesses are selling their
products and services and making a
living
making a living in a time at a time
where our economy is struggling in so
many ways
so we're talking about free speech for
everyday Americans we're talking about
small business owners who use tick tock
to grow their business
and my question is and we're going to
Pivot to the other part of the
conversation
why the Hysteria
and the panic and the targeting of tick
tock
as we know Republicans in particular
have been sounding the alarm creating a
Red Scare around China
they've been doing it in a variety of
ways when it comes to economic
competition when it comes to
semiconductor manufacturing and when it
comes to technology
in terms of tick tock's behavior and its
and its risk to National Security
it poses about the same threat that
companies like Facebook and Instagram
and YouTube and Twitter posts
so let's not marginalize and Target
Tick-Tock let's have a comprehensive
conversation about legislation that we
need Federal legislation
to make sure people who use social media
platforms are safe
and their information is secure and
their information is not being shared or
sold to third parties
because guess what
who can ban Tick-Tock but there are
still data brokers who sell our data to
other countries and businesses in other
countries they sell to the highest
bidder
so let's not have a dishonest
conversation let's not be
racist towards China and express our
xenophobia when it comes to tick tock
because American companies have done
tremendous harm to American people
Facebook
look the other way and allowed Russia to
interfere with our 2016 election
this is a fact this is well documented I
didn't hear any member of Congress talk
about banning Facebook for doing this
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and other
platforms have allowed lies and
misinformation to live on their
platforms
even though that information may have
been harmful to others
from the January 6 attack to the
genocide in Myanmar
American social media companies have
been used to facilitate harm in
tremendous ways
so let's talk about Federal legislation
to ensure the safety and security of
everyone who uses social media
and part of that is related to Banning
data Brokers and stopping them for
selling our data to the highest bidder
let's have that conversation let's have
the conversation by the way let's have
the conversation around how many people
who sign on to social media media aren't
even aware of what happens to their data
as they sign up let's have the
conversation about that
allow people the option to opt out of
having their data be shared with their
third third parties and corporations and
governments that use their data for God
knows what I mean we've allowed facial
recognition software to be sold to
hostile governments around the world
let's have an honest Global conversation
this is not just about Tick Tock this is
about social media let's talk about
social media monopolies and breaking up
big tech there was bipartisan
legislation introduced last Congress
that did not move at all obviously we
want to talk about some of the addictive
nature of these algorithms let's have a
broader more honest conversation about
social media and let's not scapegoat
Tick Tock because they happen to be
owned by a Chinese uh organization
in this time of heightened xenophobia
sense covet let's have honest
conversations
so it is my duty to bring up and my
privilege to bring up Mr Jason Linton
who is a content creator who's going to
say a few words
[Music]
hello everyone
my name is Jason Linton and I want to
share with you my story of why I'm here
today
I'm a husband and a father to three
beautiful adopted kids living in
Oklahoma
Lillian Christian and Harper Debbie
loves you
every day
I use tick tock to share the love of my
family and our journey through foster
care and adoption and through that I've
been able to create such a wonderful
community of people from all over the
world people that leave comments like I
miss my dad I wish I had a father those
things that have brought us more
together than have separated us from
across different countries all over the
world
tick tock's Community has become an
important part of my life and has helped
me connect with people from all walks of
life learning from them and growing
together both online and also offline
we have been able to build support
networks and genuine friendships
a ban on Tick Tock would be devastating
to not only my community of parents and
people that follow me but also the
millions of other communities
that I know Tick Tock has helped develop
and the people who have found a safe
place to express themselves through this
platform
a tick tock ban removes that Community
it takes away everything that we have
all built together
the support networks the Allies the
friends the safe space we have to
express ourselves the people we turn to
when we need advice all of that gone
overnight
so I'm asking our politicians don't take
away the community that we've all built
a community that laughs that loves and
supports each other in a way that
nothing else can we can solve the issues
without taking away something so
precious to us all
next I welcome Tiffany to share her
story
oh
hi everyone my name is Tiffany Yu and I
want to share with you why Tick Tock is
so important to me as a disability
advocate
so a little over 25 years ago at the age
of nine I became disabled as a result of
a car accident that also took the life
of my dad I permanently paralyzed my arm
and sustained a few broken bones in one
of my legs
and today I'm the CEO and founder of a
disability advocacy organization called
diversibility that I started in 2009.
like all good stories mine starts by
getting fired from a job
I had to get creative about making ends
meet and so I was airbn being out my
apartment and selling other jewelry and
other things on Craigslist
but it wasn't until I downloaded Tick
Tock in March of 2020 that my advocacy
really took off 11 years after I'd
started doing disability advocacy work
Tick Tock has really been a game changer
for me it's allowed me to reach new
audiences millions of people unlock new
ways to generate income to support my
advocacy and Empower an entire group of
Disability Advocates to find their voice
and build their careers
with my advocacy hot and I want to share
a couple stats with you disabled people
are twice as likely to live in poverty
and the unemployment rate for disabled
Americans is twice that of those without
disabilities
so since joining the learn on Tick Tock
program in July of 2020 I've not only
secured over six figures of Creator
income I have a book coming out in 2024
and all of which are supporting my dream
of advocating on behalf of my own
Community the disabled community
a passion that I know many people in
Congress share
tick tock's Been instrumental in
accelerating my advocacy and I know that
I'm not alone
it's become a vital platform for
Advocates across society and across
across the political Spectrum to connect
share their stories and help change
people's lives
so to Congress
I urge you to consider an imp the impact
that a ban on Tick Tock would have on
Advocates like myself
Tick Tock has provided us with a
powerful tool to raise awareness promote
inclusion and change the world and in
addition to that find Community where
we've previously been so socially
isolated and excluded before we find
each other on social media and on tick
tock
a band takes away the connections we've
built silencing communities that
continue to be underrepresented and not
given a voice
now I'd like to welcome Bay to share
what Tick Tock means to her
hello everyone my name is badri Nicole
I'm back in the kitchen with Bae and I
want to talk to you about why Tick Tock
has been so important to me as a black
queer woman in business and in this
country I run a bakery called Coco's
confectionary Kitchen located in
Columbus Ohio and Tick Tock has been
essential in helping me build my
business over the past few years
a band will create obstacles for me both
financially and professionally as Tick
Tock is at the Forefront of our brand
strategy I personally know that I am not
alone in this fear as I am a Content
developer working with businesses around
the globe to help them to understand
social media and the platforms where
their businesses can thrive
Tick Tock has allowed me to encourage my
clients and millions of business owners
alike to enter the digital space and
explore the new possibilities they have
to connect with their customer base
aside from the business for me this is a
very personal mission it's not about
sales and exposure it's about the impact
I and people that look like me can have
on our community simply by accessing and
contributing to The Tick Tock space
as everyone in this room and all those
watching know this country has not
always been the most fair or equal for
black and brown individuals for a group
of people whose ancestors have built or
helped build this country and the even
the ground we're standing on it can be
discouraging that after centuries we're
still operating a step behind in the
social media space these issues are no
different we often hear stories of
suppression and intense at Erasure for
people of color on their platforms it is
not an issue that we've endured easily
but we've persevered through no matter
how many difficulties it created
thankfully Tick Tock has cultivated a
safe space that has allowed black and
brown people in the community to share
knowledge and tips on entrepreneurship
and share ways that we can use our
influence to cultivate change in ways we
never have before
Tick Tock is a critical tool for me to
promote entrepreneurship and Inspire the
next generation of black and brown
Business Leaders
I get the honor of sharing my
experiences and get to offer advice to
others who are just starting out helping
them to understand how to harness their
power that they possess
I can tell you without question that the
next generation of black business owners
are going to come from The Tick Tock
platform if you ban Tick Tock then you
put at risk putting a cap on the
Ambitions of a whole generation of
wealth creators who will have vital
networks taken from them overnight I
want to leave you with this yesterday
while visiting your beautiful city I had
the opportunity to visit the Jefferson
Memorial I was of course overwhelmed
with its beauty and great history but
what stood out to me most was a powerful
quote etched onto the wall something I
learned and was not aware of the quote
indicated that Jefferson was not a
proponent of change in our country's
laws however he understood the need for
change to take place when necessary he
understood that with the evolution of
the world over time as things Advanced
change would be necessary but he urged
our country's lawmakers the importance
to fully understand the changes being
considered and the people that would be
affected as a result
I urge you all to take his advice and do
the same join us on the app learn and
gain a better understanding of it simply
by experiencing it feel the power of our
community before changing the lives of
over 150 million people across the world
through this band that you guys are
proposing
allow us your constituents to hear your
story and use the app as it was intended
to connect with us on an even greater
level please be encouraged to take this
step before taking any others thank you
for this incredible opportunity to share
a piece of my story
yeah
I would now like to introduce
representative mark pocan from Wisconsin
thanks Jamal um so I'm here because I've
seen this problem too often in Congress
this is now my sixth term here where we
have a real problem that exists uh
what's happening with social media in
general with data with disinformation
with Russians being able to buy uh ads
on platforms like Facebook and that's
what we should be addressing but like I
see happen all too often that's not what
we're doing instead the debate has gone
to whether or not we should ban a single
platform and it's getting lost on that
rather than the very real issues that
Congress should take on but if we take
that issue on that means you're taking
on also American companies you're taking
on lobbyists that these companies have
you're taking on some of the richest
people in the country who make
contributions to both Democrats and
Republicans so we're not addressing the
actual problem and instead the debate
has gone to Let's ban Tick Tock well
there's a couple reasons why if you've
ever watched members of Congress in
hearings talk about issues like this uh
it's cringe-worthy it's tick tock worthy
uh content to watch uh people who are
above uh the average age I think of most
people use tick tock trying to explain
it because they've never done it they've
never looked at it look I I have watched
dogs jump over couches and Destroy
tables I have watched the Wednesday
dance more times that I can count I have
watched people do magic tricks I've
watched people do interviews I've
watched food being made none of that is
a threat to this country we are stronger
than the Wednesday dance
and yet most members would never know
that because they've never been there
there is a real problem and we should be
addressing it and it includes Tick Tock
and Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
and other platforms about our data and
our privacy of our data and selling our
data and allowing misinformation but
that is not what's being addressed when
people say they want to ban Tick Tock
and there's a lot of people here who are
either individuals who are using this as
a way to express their creative
backgrounds their community building
that they have within this and that is
not a threat to this country what is the
threat is when you challenge First
Amendment rights what is a threat to
this country is when you become
xenophobic and you decide one company
from one country that you want to put on
a list is not going to work but at the
end of the day we do have a job as
members of Congress and that is to
protect our data and to protect
disinformation but we're not doing that
by a simple ban on Tick Tock so I just
hope we are wiser that people who the
median age in Congress is at 57 and a
half I think right now maybe watch Tick
Tock or have at least their staff show
it to them and maybe they'll see that
the threat is not in a single platform
but the threat is out there around
issues around social media but that
means taking on a lot of lobbyists and
rich people here in this country and it
is something that we should do
Mark is a magician by the way so if you
want to book him you can hit up his
office I'm dead serious about that uh I
would like to bring up representative
Robert Garcia thank you
thank you thank you thank you
um first uh I I want to thank you know
Congressman thank you for your
leadership on on this issue
um the truth is is that I consider
myself a uh Tick Tock super consumer and
so I uh it's great to see so many
digital creators that are out here and
like was said earlier from some of the
the creators and folks are involved uh
Tick Tock is a lot of things to a lot of
different people and first and foremost
it is entertainment it is fun I get most
of my laughs just from my my for you
page which a lot of you are probably on
uh I mean Pedro Pascal is featured
prominently uh right now
um on my for you page but but also the
thing to think about is what it's done
for small businesses uh the amount of
Revenue it's actually bringing back into
the system for all of these content
creators for brands for businesses
across the country and for the profiles
that's raising of folks that would not
have the same voice on any other
platform
I'll speak also as someone that's queer
myself as one of the few members in in
the Congress that is gay uh the fact
that there's so many young queer kids
queer creators they're able to find
themselves in this space share
information feel comfortable in some
cases come out share their stories is so
important and honestly it's done best on
The Tick Tock platform than any other
platform social media platform uh that
currently exists uh certainly in the
United States and so for for all the
queer creators that are here just thank
you for what you do for our community
it's it's an enormous step forward and
then to also speak uh what it's also
done to uplift uh black and brown
creators uh folks that are from uh
communities that uh need that need us to
support that need our support
consistently is also incredible what we
what we heard earlier is true
there are so many black creators so many
Latino latinx creators they're creating
Brands and platforms they never would
have been able to do on any other
platform and it's uplifting those voices
in new ways which is really really
important so I'm just here to say just
those two things the first is do not ban
Tick Tock we need it consider me an ally
and a strong supporter and second to
reinforce everybody up here we all
understand that privacy rights are
important we all supported the idea that
individual people should have the
ability to keep information in private
but there's a better way of working
together so that we can both keep Tick
Tock address the privacy concerns and
allow all these creators uh to thrive
and so thank you all for being here
Congressman thank you very much and
happy to be a supporter
[Applause]
we can keep Tick Tock we can protect
freedom of speech and we could deal with
the privacy concerns at the same time we
could do both and right now we're not
trying to do both it's my honor to call
up Cali Goodwin
hi everyone my name is Callie Goodwin
and I'm from South Carolina and I'm the
founder of Sparks ajoyco sparkster joyco
is a greeting card company with the goal
of spreading Joy to the World through
handwritten cards I launched my business
on Tick Tock in the summer of 2020 in
the midst of the pandemic and the midst
of coveted quarantine and the goal was
to just bring more Joy to the World in a
time when there was a lot of sadness and
heartbreak and isolation
I have sold over 35 000 cards through my
website but 95 percent of those orders
come from Tick Tock followers I'm going
to say that again 95 of my orders come
because of tick tock
Tick Tock has allowed me to Showcase my
products our process engage with
customers and build a community
it has allowed me to share my passion
for spreading joy and for handwritten
cards
a tick tock band wouldn't just put my
business at risk 95 of my livelihood
would disappear overnight
along with this entire community of
creators and um
customers that I have built over the
platform I've currently got about 90 000
followers that follow me through the
highs and the lows the ups and the Downs
they celebrate the wins with me and They
Mourn the losses with me and a ban on
Tic Tac Tick Tock would
um would get rid of that and it would be
devastating
but this isn't just about my story we
could spend hours talking about the
thousands of small businesses that are
impacted by this app
I know that there are so many that have
used Tick Tock to build their brands and
to build their communities and to sell
products and there is a massive economic
impact because of tick tock
a band would erase a source of income
for millions of small business owners
across America
it's not an exact exaggeration to say
that a harm it would harm a growing and
blooming access to small businesses
so I urge you let's find a solution that
does not require a ban because the
reality is is that a ban would not
benefit the American people there's 150
million Americans on Tick Tock right now
and we would lose the ability to create
Community to support small businesses
and to find educational resources Mental
Health Resources and so much more
um I'm so thankful that this app has
given me the chance to grow my business
and to seek this entrepreneur Journey
that would not be possible without it so
thank you
you know Robert I just realized
something
Republicans ain't got no swag that's why
they want to ban Tick Tock Republicans
ain't got no swag that's the problem and
I mentioned that in the context of
engaging young people in the Democratic
process
so I started using Tick Tock
consistently when it took the
Republicans 14 votes to get to speaker
McCarthy and I would just give updates
to people on Tick Tock and what I
realized was holy snap people really are
paying attention and they are engaged
and they're excited they want to hear
more and they want to learn more and
then I started just posting things about
my day posting votes that we've taken
posted posting conversations I was
having with my staff uh talking about
different issues and people wanting
wanted to learn more and so by using
Tick Tock in a variety of ways
entertainment engagement education we
are pulling people in and making them
more a part of the democratic process
and making our democracy stronger that's
right one of the reasons I would argue
and I know there's probably some polling
somewhere that we were able to resist
this so-called huge Red Wave is because
Democrats do a better job of engaging
young people overall
and using Tick Tock is a part of that so
to the Democratic members of Congress
let's do the right thing here again
comprehensive social media reform as it
relates to privacy
and security
absolutely but we have to uplift freedom
of speech and the creativity there's so
many content creators are bringing to
the American people last but not least I
want to bring up Mr Robert Lucas to say
a few words
[Applause]
everyone my name is Robert Lucas and I'm
a self-taught cake artist from Georgia
creating art has always been a passion
of mine and through the platform I've
been able to channel that creativity and
take my bacon Creations to a much wider
audience than I ever thought could be
possible I used to work in I.T and now I
make videos that go out to Millions to
enjoy who watch watching me bake
increasingly challenging Creations often
based around big cultural moments and
movements not only do I inspire
I entertain I educate and I also break
down stereotypes because it's not often
that you see someone that looks like me
baking and decorating cakes
Tick Tock is doing much more than just
give me exposure it has it has actually
allowed me to increase my income by 700
and this extra income has allowed me to
support to support myself build a studio
and pay staff and then this platform is
taken away then I'm not sure if I'll be
able to continue to do that Tick Tock
has given me and countless others like
me the opportunity to showcase our
talents and make a living doing what we
love so I urge you to consider the
impact that banning Tick Tock could have
on people like me it would not only take
away a source of income but it will also
stifle creativity and prevent talented
individuals from sharing their art with
the world thank you thank you so much
okay we would now like to take a few
questions
Director of National Intelligence
they've all expressed major national
security concerns about tech talks even
the president supports bipartisan
legislation that would give him powers
to ban Tick Tock is President Biden
racist
yeah
so usually when there's an issue of
National Security concern they hold a
bipartisan Congressional briefing on
that particular issue we have not
received a bipartisan Congressional
briefing on the National Security risk
of tick tock number one number two again
you know what happens is a certain party
usually Republicans whip something like
this into hysteria and we move way too
rapidly in the wrong direction to write
and pass legislation let's take a breath
take a step back and ask ourselves is
this the best legislation at this moment
to really protect individuals privacy
data information and does this make the
entire social media landscape safer for
everyone that's the question we need to
be asking and answering yes
advocated for selling to talk to
us-based company do you ensure that the
Privacy secures around that National
Security risk regarding China is
advocated do you see that as a viable
option for a path forward is moving this
to the us moving those data over to the
us where the the proper safety and
privacy regulations can be you know
brought by the U.S Congress push to sell
Facebook when we know clearly they allow
Russia to interfere with the 2016
presidential election
exactly right the problem here is the
isolation of tick tock because they're a
Chinese company that's the problem and
it feeds it feeds into the xenophobic's
hysteria that we're seeing throughout
the country we got we have to have a
larger comprehensive conversation about
social media the benefits and the harms
and and right legislation to deal with
social media overall yes thank you thank
you Jackson Richmond Times why do you
believe it's important to promote a
company whose parent company bite dance
is partly owned by the Chinese Communist
Party
this is not about tick tock this is
about social media
freedom of expression Safety and
Security for all people we just happen
to be here talking about Tick Tock
because that's the focus of a so-called
band of or the selling of the company
I'm not I'm personally not feeding into
the xenophobia the hysteria and the
fears take a breath take a step back
have a larger conversation I'm very
clear on how harmful Facebook Instagram
Twitter and uh YouTube have been just to
name a few I mean president Donald Trump
used Twitter to help facilitate an
insurrection
an attack on the U.S Capitol by U.S
citizens so while we're worried about
China harming our country we are harming
harming our the kind of things that
you've advocated for here today we're
having those
in those many Americans support the
conversation that we're having
to share American data with the Chinese
government
well personally I don't trust nobody
and I don't trust uh again American
social media companies when they say
they don't do that
trying to broaden the
cop stop can we not be so myopic in our
view
what we talk about as a single entity
his problems on social media yes and no
we got to fix them yes or no yes you ban
one company they're still David broker
selling my data that God knows who out
there and I don't even have a say in it
that ain't right
social media monopolies that ain't right
lies and misinformation
that ain't right across the board
so let's talk about the entire landscape
not one cup